richtige entscheidung dass das vollzogen
wird was lange angekündigt ist dass die
quarantäne denen jemand gehen muss der
ungeimpft ist in den fällen in den
quarantäne angeordnet wird ohne die
lohnfortzahlung stattfindet denn es gibt
ja mittlerweile genügend impfstoff der
auch schon seit langer zeit zur
verfügung steht klar ist dass wir das
aber in diesem fall machen müssen für
die frage der quarantäne aber eins ist
mir bei der gelegenheit auch sehr
wichtig hier zu betonen es muss so sein
dass die lohnfortzahlung die ansonsten
gewährleistet wird zum beispiel im
krankheitsfall dass die völlig
unangetastet bleibt das ist etwas was
seit ewigkeiten seit 100 jahren so
geregelt ist dass man unabhängig von
seinem gesundheitszustand anspruch auf
die lohnfortzahlung hat und das muss
auch so sein das gilt im übrigen auch
für viele andere fälle ich bin dagegen
dass man zum beispiel
versicherungstarife differenziert nach
dem gesundheits krankheitszustand oder
ob man besonders sportliche nicht
sportlich lebte das alles soll und darf
es in deutschland nicht geben aber in
diesem fall geht es ja darum ob man
gewissermaßen eine vorsichtsmaßnahme die
ergriffen werden muss
deshalb in quarantäne verbringen muss
weil man sich nicht hat impfen lassen
obwohl die möglichkeit existiert
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
können weil es für sie keine
impfempfehlung gibt oder weil sie aus
gesundheitlichen gründen sich nicht
impfen lassen können werden ja weiter
finanziell entschädigt das ist ein ganz
schlimmer mord was ganz ganz furchtbares
was da passiert ist dass ein junger mann
ums leben gekommen der einfach das getan
hat was wir alle wollen und auf eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme hingewiesen hat und
deshalb muss man sich schon sehr große
sorgen machen dass diejenigen die mit
ihrem schlimmen sprüchen die
gesellschaft auseinander treiben eben
auch letztendlich an million schaffen
indem so furchtbare gewalttaten dann
stattfinden und die haben auch die
verantwortung dafür das ist eben nicht
etwas harmloses dass einige darin das
netz schreiben was sie auch flugblätter
schreiben oder was sie in die gegend
brüllen und deshalb muss das auch ganz
ganz klar zurückgewiesen werden diese
wahl ist nicht nur richtig richtig
spannend sondern diese wahl ist eine
richtungswahl machen wir weiter so wie
bisher
und dürfen wir uns vor den großen
herausforderungen und krisen dieser zeit
weg oder schaffen wir jetzt einen echten
aufbruch und wir als grüne robert habeck
und ich als kanzlerkandidatin wir sind
zutiefst davon überzeugt
dass nicht nur in unserem land so viel
mehr steckt sondern das passt hier bei
ihnen bei euch in baden württemberg vor
zehn jahren angegangen worden ist ein
echten aufbruch für erneuerung zu
schaffen dass es jetzt auch die aufgabe
im bund und dafür treten wir an
keine halben sachen mehr beim
klimaschutz wir brauchen eine klima
bundesregierung und dafür braucht es
starke starke grüne
ich glaube dass wir vor allem familien
und geringverdiener entlasten müssen und
dafür sorgen dass kinder in aus der
armut kommen und deswegen die
einkommensteuer leicht erhöhen und
familien und kinder endlich entlassen zu
können auch das ist diese auswahl bei
dieser bundestagswahl
unterstützen wir diejenigen die es
wirklich brauchen
oder entlasten wir die die ohnehin schon
am meisten haben
und das ist kein gegeneinander das ist
kein gegeneinander weil natürlich
brauchen wir starke unternehmen brauchen
wir einen starken mittelstand brauchen
wir starke schultern in dieser
gesellschaft aber vor allem diese
gesellschaft braucht eine zukunft die
bedeutet dass jugendliche vernünftig
ausgebildet werden dass nicht wie jetzt
jedes zehnte kind die schule verlässt
ohne schulabschluss und durch corona
sind es doppelt so viele sondern das was
wir jetzt investieren in kinder und
jugendliche ist auch die sicherung die
rückversicherung für unser aller zukunft
und das gehört zusammen
wirtschaftskompetenz und umweltkompetenz
und deshalb bin ich auch froh
dass mit im team friedrich merz ist ein
mann der was von wirtschaft versteht ja
das ist mir klar das ist mir klar dass
sie da aufschreien aber das ist ein mann
der ist nicht vom hörsaal in die
plenarsaal gegangen der schon mal
gearbeitet in seinem leben hesse und
verschieden wir brauchen auch im
bundestag leute die man ihr eigenes geld
verdient haben dahinten wink die ganze
zeit jemand mit der cd a fahne bei mir
im landeskabinett sitzt karl josef
laumann ein maschinenschlosser der weiß
mehr von der arbeit der menschen als
mancher ideologe bei den
sozialdemokraten der immer nur wie wir
einen unsinn gemacht hat in seinem leben
wir müssen einfach aufhören jedem
vorzuschreiben wie er zu leben hat wir
zu reden hat das könne die leute schon
selbst entscheiden was für sie richtig
ist und das ist die frage um die es geht
wir merken auch eine aggression im netz
von allen seiten ich bin lange von
rechts da bekämpft wurden weil ich in
der flüchtlingskrise die entscheidung
von angela merkel für richtig gehalten
habe da waren die rechten er die die
kritisierten jetzt sind es aber auch die
linken jetzt sind es aktivisten der ton
ist übrigens häufig der gleiche und
deshalb müssen wir zu einer gesellschaft
kommen wo wir wieder sprachlich abrüsten
julia hat es ja am beispiel idar
oberstein erzählt da fängt im netz die
hetze an wir haben es bei walter lütke
erlebt jahre lang ist er es im netz
beschimpft worden und dann ist einer
dann am ende so radikalisiert und zieht
die waffe und ermordet jemanden dem
müssen wir uns entgegenstellen und ich
sage klipp und klar und ich sag dir
klipp und klar wir haben da klarheit wir
sagen die afd die alle diese themen
nutzt um die leute aufzuhetzen sie
gehört nicht in deutsche parlamente wir
müssen sie raus bringen aus den
parlamenten mit ihrem hass ihren
ressentiments